non so se vi ricordate come finito
l'ultimo episodio ma è finito così
doveva no amico
aspetta aspetta
siccome io ho una vita solo 23 anni e
vorrei arrivare a 80 non giocando solo a
minecraft facciamo che ripartiamo da
questo punto bene ciao amico
già allora io ho dato io colpito ti ho
colpito per andare di light si è andato
di un se salta la non lo fa non l'ho
fatto uno spingerti fortissima beh erano
rimasti qua manca far cure per niente
siamo a metà percorso
ma così come lo lager all'inizio queste
sono tutte istanze da superare e siamo
arrivati qua questa che stanzia occhio
che se vai tutto giunti teletrasportare
un'altra parte
ho capito ma cosa devo fare subito
questa è una bella domanda ho capito ho
capito che cosa hai capito
qui di blocchi lanterne sotto che ha no
vabbè sto male ma sto malissimo
c'è un muro invisibile ma chi no e ci
sei pure riuscito
non so come mai fatto e bellissimo sono
scarso amico
porca vacca sono scarsissimo ok ok ok ma
perché sono stupido nel deretano dentro
proprio dai no sono caduto nella stanza
di prima surreal power senza occhiali li
facciamo
cosa c'è da fare tutto ma per t papa
quindi non mi ricorda che come si faccia
sta roba
addio che rottura
no no veri che sono scemi di corna che
di come si faceva l'altro o ce l'ho
fatta amico che cos'è cos'è sta roba
divertiti qui cosa devo fare qua saltare
tanto ma è scusato dov'è finito è
arrivato qua fino al giro interno vi
stupirò
scommetti che ti stupirò la pro am ha
scritto a mano dalla difficoltà dove sta
allora è di chi siamo e non capisco dove
dove dove cadere e poi una volta
arrivato al giro interno cosa faccio qui
e continua non lo so e poi c'è un buco
in buco
e poi c'è una salita e ce l'ho fatta se
arrivato a quella dopo ma come hai fatto
ma è bene il giro interno non è
difficilissimo ma ci sono delle fornaci
lei quella villa lui la guarda il
saltatore guarda lo guarda il saltatore
mammamia oggi quanto cari co.co.co oggi
quanto carico beni vieni vieni 6
coraggio vieni qua ricariche saltelli ma
che ok gli occhi semi non cerco di
arrivare dall'altra parte ma no
ascoltate non sa neanche dove sto
andando in questo momento profonde
fornaci che ho fatto pure quello dopo lo
lasciano tutti tutti sto facendo ciao
amico ciao ci vediamo su ci vediamo su
un altro gioco a questo macello
no questo macedo salire intorno alla
colonna come si fa questo hai anche
avuto fortissimi concluso
aspetta aspetta che devo fare l'ultimo
mamma mia che il giocatore è in ferro
hanno fatti 5 senza mai cadere neanche
in uno e poi c'è un vivo a dosi
lontanissimo quasi un villager ciao
amico
vabbè comunque qua non c'è una stanza
non serve a niente bello sto posto
andiamo avanti permesso solo fare 4
altro ma mi sa che devo passare ma sei
arrivato fino qua gol bravo amico come
hai fatto come ho fatto a pasta roba
anche cazzeggiato un sacco qui nei miei
miei non saltato qua non so come andare
avanti
quindi è una bella domanda come faccio a
fare sta roba forse da qua devo andare
qui sopra corretto sì all è perfetto in
questo livello
solo per trovare la strada un macello te
lo giuro è difficilissimo trovare la
strada e nascosti ma comunque sono in
uno dei punti più alti nella mappa prima
di arrivare alla torre dopo avere più o
meno tutti altri livelli e ti assicuro
che sono facili
divertenti molto simpatici simpatici
soprattutto miche e dimmi che sono bravo
salta la salta sulla nuova o dai credici
credici bravissimo ma trova la strada
per beni di qua no vedi che sono stupido
nell'anima porca eva
no no no vieni vieni dove sono io non ce
la farei mai devi fare così gare di
saltare qua poi qui ma vogliamo
scherzare ma il bacio messo un ora per
trovarla
ho già fatta già fatto che il parma non
so come mi sono un pò chinato forse c'è
una roba allucinante a con con shift di
madonna stanno sbagliando l'ultimo salto
un troglodita bene via veramente è stato
orribile arriva il film 4 giuro non farò
mai più perché sempre più ambìto di
megas roba da oggi oggi ho messo il
turbo la fenomeno bene ho fatto anche
quello dopo fi tempo ma come siamo a
quello dopo per è diviso in giugno e poi
ci passo no qua tra l'altro dei vivi per
passare a livello dopo di usare l'acqua
capito ma tu non puoi non puoi usare
l'acqua già per andare su pervenire si
usava allora allora abbiamo degli dei
deficienti tutti e due esclude ma a vedi
che bloccato volevi volevo tantissime
niente cesta scala qui però non so come
raggiungerla a c'è un coso di slime va a
cagare mai visto e qui sta piovendo
amico riesco proprio già un fenomeno un
genio oddio grande grazie bene ragazzi
funziona tutto da dio
la pioggia e nostra amica una voce
bottone cosa dio
esclusa la porta ho fatto saltare in
aria la porta amico
ma scusami ma è mycroft ci sono gli
effetti esplosivi
non avevo la più pallida idea che figata
vabbè comunque sono avanti di un paio di
livello e fai saltare guarda vieni vieni
aspetto aspetterà di qua guarda ho visto
come ha fatto saltare la porta non si
facesse fare schiacciare bottoni dietro
di te non mi chiedere come ok ma dai
porca vacca di vita ma basta concentrati
dai mamma mia quanto storto nei salti ma
poi perché questo è ghiacciata pitto
aspetta questa difficile nord america ma
lo vedi che sei uno spermatozoo lo vedi
guardate dove va ad ora di nuovo sono
alla laica la ci sei mai andato sulla
scala no poi fatto arrivare sia allora
di nuovo solo slime sulla scala non
smettendo slime sai mi sa che con lo
slime perché non riesco a fare il salto
perché salto c'è un dubbio ci devo
girare o no ma allora allora ma no ma no
dai
ma se facciamo in serie adesso basta
cioè non è che posso fare le visite su
youtube con un gioco così cioè non
impone che posso esaurirli frega niente
delle views e mette a giocare a barbie
me ne frega nulla arriva ve lo dico con
pietro si siano no no no cosa con pietro
sono due volte 2 che sbaglio ii 2 è lo
slime mia mamma se di metterla metto a
giocare minecraft lo fa mai
che fastidio per questo gioco esiste
perché si perché deve esistere cossiga
grazie grazie grazie
avevo bisogno per un grazie ok ok ok ok
crowe centrale lo slime line più scalas
e pecore
possiamo cambiare già possiamo giocare a
non so come faccia presto parti spiega
mi può risultare può ricercare nella
scala ma non troppo tutto sono svolti
con un accadendo è stato stavo cadendo
all'indietro di complimenti ma dai
aiutami amico amico aiuto prestato a
fare qui cosa faccia gola alla tua
sinistra dai sì ce l'ho fatta ok sul
muro perfetto no vabbè impossibile vai
mi sono chinato sono stato bravissimo
ciavatta è stato difficilissimo vieni
amico ti do la mano e vabbè grazie
salta sull'altro a quello davanti è sì
beh ovvio bravissimo poi sul bur hoc sul
muro e poi devi fare gli altri a questa
parte difficile ma ora in bocca in bocca
in bocca vai bravo bravo vieni qua ma
bravo va bene così
qui qui è questo casino diavolo serve il
vettore scala le scale nel cane ok calde
già fatta ci ho fatto solo forte cosa
può fare qua ma scusami
cosa c'è di così il parkour tagli cosa
presente cosa devo fare
così dicendo scemo ma che pezzo è sì si
può fare anche se lo slime alle cose che
lo slime no
lo sapevo madonna devi morire e lo giuro
guarda ho proposto le mani tanto quadri
di tornare indietro
non è vero ti giuro no il parkour in due
equity capito dall'inizio
io sia un cazzo te lo giuro su dio
ok no dai vedi che cade da solo come un
ebete madonna ok vestito da quasi nove
membro aggiunge ora devi saltare sul
madonna figurati ma poi scusami ma non
non puoi raggiungere ma sei scemo novara
non poi ma va no si può scherzare perché
da qua scusa il blocco design eco la
centrale immagino spero e prego si era
proprio apple inchinatevi tutti adesso
aree del parkour
poi c'è la lava e se muoio potrei g
potrebbero girare le balle poi c'è un
cartello better luck birther lac next
time o 26 no no a sei dentro la lava tu
sei caduto no mori se cadi dentro al mio
dio ca succede
dimmi cosa succede o buttarmi che io non
lo so prova molto faq maghetti ma sei
scemo
[Musica]